my question first of all to naturally
obviously in the first bill Jane was
very much a spectator whereas this time
she's right in the middle force world I
wonder if that was part of what excited
me about the prospect of coming back I
guess with Kristen Tom how nice was it
at this time how beautiful third wheel
yeah it was it was exciting to get to
come back and work with everyone and
we're joining this time and also because
Jane gets to go to Asgard this time I
was looking up to get to work more with
Tom and testings with Renee and Anthony
too were amazing and I just got to
admire from the farm and then also just
continue the fun rapport with with cat
and Stella and Chris and it was
definitely a lot of laughing yes it was
brilliant Natalie I loved working with
Nathalie in in the first film
Loki's aware of Jane Foster's presence
and refers to her but it was so fun to
see what happens when the two share the
same space violence as you see as
question for Natalie I believe your mum
keeps a scrapbook of photos that she
allows out on set with such
eventualities and all these shots in the
flat scene are you through the ages do
you wish that discrepant will go away as
someone who can look at themselves on
DVD h10
are you not worried about you Oh image
yeah I guess I guess the funny thing is
that it is I think the same set of
photos that she always lends out for
every movie our gun for the past 20
years there you know more background
people aren't really focused via all
sorts of different people have been like
photoshopped into them you know
interests and require
you